i do want to bring you a piece of news
that i think is really worthwhile and
good so
a bunch of people who i am personally
friendly with
have decided that they are going to
launch a new university i think this is
great to understand why you have to
understand that right now universities
are largely a scam unless you're in an
engineering program unless you're in
science technology engineering and math
universities are basically a scam
according to a piece by preston cooper
in the wall street journal college is
expensive but worth it or is it college
graduates generally make more money than
those without a degree but a closer look
reveals that for many the benefit is not
spread equally and a significant
minority of students are worse off for
having gone to college in a report for
the foundation for research on equal
opportunity
i calculated the return on investment
for nearly 30 000 different bachelor's
degree programs i estimated the median
lifetime earnings for graduates of each
program based on education department
and census data subtracted tuition costs
and wages missed while enrolled i then
compared that number with a scenario in
which those students didn't attend
college using the earnings of high
school graduates as a baseline and then
adjusting for demographics cognitive
ability and family background as a
result i was able to compare the net
boost in lifetime earnings students got
from each college degree
the results show that 28 of college
degrees almost a third weighted by
enrollment do not have a net positive
return
more than a quarter of students are in
programs that are actually a net loss
for them
those students often obsess over where
they get in majors have the most way
over future earnings i've talked about
this at length whenever people say that
there is a
racial differential in college graduates
in earnings
you have to adjust for the majors black
students tend not to engineer not to
major in engineering as much as asian
students for example so you're going to
get a wide variance in terms of earning
potential somebody with an education
degree does not earn the same as
somebody with an engineering degree
programs in engineering computer science
economics and nursing all yield a high
return often increasing their students
net lifetime earnings by half a million
dollars or more but a majority of
programs in art music philosophy and
psychology leave their average students
financially worse off
so if you were given the financial
choice between going to a college and
majoring in philosophy and not going to
the college and getting a job
you're better off in all likelihood
not going to college
a majority of those programs leave
average students financially worse off
some students defy averages of course
there are some music majors who will get
rich and some engineers who will fail
but
that is not the average
one of the nation's highest return
programs is the computer science major
at harvard that degree has an expected
value of more than three million dollars
but attending the nation's most elite
school is no guarantee of financial
security harvard's ethnic and gender
studies program leaves its students
worse off by about forty seven thousand
dollars on average according to these
estimates
so if you major in lesbian dance theory
at harvard you actually lose money
because who the hell wants to hire a
lesbian dance theory major from harvard
besides major another important factor
for negative return is low completion
rates if a student graduates in four
years the increase in earnings is
usually enough to justify the cost of
college but if you take five or six
years to graduate then the cost of
tuition and time spent out of the labor
force start to add up
if you fail to graduate at all you're
stuck with most of the cost of college
but few of the benefits and by the way
there's a huge dropout rate at america's
universities
so if you look
at the full cost of education and not
just the education but also
all of the other costs
like the the subsidies that colleges pay
for student education
the share of bachelor's degrees programs
with negative returns is all the way up
to 37 percent so almost four in ten
bachelor's degrees are less worth are
worth less than the money spent on the
degree okay so what does this mean well
it means that we need to radically
change how education is done in the
united states it means that the promise
of university is basically a lie for a
huge number of people i've been talking
about this for a long time
and i'm speaking as a graduate of some
prestigious universities at ucla and
harvard law school and as i've said
harvard law school is worth the money
because you finish up and now you're a
lawyer from harvard and that means
you're going to make a lot of money a
poli-sci degree from from ucla maybe
it's worth the money and maybe it's not
that one is a lot more dicey and there's
a case to be made that we really should
do is move toward a system where you go
directly from high school into an
apprenticeship program if you want to be
a lawyer for example
because what you actually pick up in a
polyside program at ucla has almost
nothing to do with what you're learning
in law school at least in the first year
there's also a good case to be made that
law school should be two years rather
than three
but credentialing has become the thing
credentialing is a big thing in american
life and the reason for that is we
refuse to look simple facts in the face
okay those facts include the fact that
some people are smarter and work harder
than others and so instead of just
recognizing that which you can tell
right out of high school we have decided
to create an airsats method for
evaluating whether people are likely to
be good employees or not
so if you give me somebody like anybody
if you meet their sat scores and their
gpa from high school
i can say with a high level of certainty
whether this person will be a good
employee or not
i don't need that person to go to a
four-year college to tell me that and i
especially don't need them to go waste
two hundred thousand dollars in a
four-year college majoring in english in
order to tell me whether they will be a
good employee or not in fact i would
rather hire the kid directly out of high
school if they have a good sat score and
a good gpa and good values and have them
go to a college where they're really
just being indoctrinated into the
language of wokeness and so this is why
it's one of the reasons why i'm excited
about the launching of this new
university it's called university of
austin
pano canelos is the new head of
university of austin he was the
president of st john's college in
annapolis
and it's got a lot of people who i think
are just wonderful they're launching
this college the four-year degree is not
available just yet they're going to
start with some unaccredited programs
then they're going to roll out the
accredited programs in the near future
it's exciting stuff because this needs
to happen competition is the way forward
here panel canals writes
so much is broken in america but higher
education might be the most fractured
institution of all there's a gaping
chasm between the promise and the
reality of higher education yale's motto
is lux at veritas light and truth
harvard proclaims that veritas young men
and women of stanford are told to lift
the free height wet the wind of freedom
blows these are soaring words but in
these top schools and in so many others
can we actually claim that the pursuit
of truth remains the highest virtue so
we honestly believe that the crucial
means to that end freedom of inquiry and
civil discourse will prevail when a
liberalism has become a pervasive
feature of campus life the numbers tell
the story as well as any anecdote you've
read in the headlines or heard within
your own circles nearly a quarter of
american academics in the social
sciences or humanities endorse ousting a
colleague for having the wrong opinion
about hot button issues like immigration
or gender differences over a third of
conservative academics and phd students
say they had been threatened with
disciplinary actions for their views
four out of five american phd students
are willing to discriminate against
right-leaning scholars according to a
report by the center for the study of
partisanship and ideology
the picture among undergrads steven
bleecker and heterodox academy's 2020
campus expression survey 62 percent of
sampled college students agreed that the
climate on their campus prevented
students from saying things they believe
nearly 70 percent of students favor
reporting professors if the professor
says something students find offensive
according to a challenge institute for
global innovation survey the foundation
for individual rights in education
reports at least 491 disinvitation
campaigns since 2000 roughly half
successful
the reality is that many universities
writes
hanno canelos the the new head of
university of austin
he says the reality is that many
universities no longer have an incentive
to create an environment where
intellectual dissent is protected and
fashionable opinions scrutinized
the priority at most other institutions
is simply to avoid financial collapse
they're in a desperate contest to
attract a dwindling number of students
who are less and less capable of paying
skyrocketing tuition over the last three
decades the cost of a degree from a
four-year private college has nearly
doubled the cost of a degree from a
public university has nearly tripled the
nation's students owe 1.7 trillion
dollars in loans
and by the way nearly 40 percent of
people who are pursuing a college degree
don't get one
okay so to go back to the stats that
means that 40 of people who pursue a
college degree are out
of the remaining 60 percent about
one-third are going to spend more money
on the college degree than the degree is
worth
so that means college is a really really
bad bargain at this point
so
say the folks at university of austin
as i write this i'm sitting in my new
office in balmy austin texas where i
moved three months ago from my previous
post as president of st john's college
in annapolis i'm not alone our project
began with a small gathering of those
concerned about the state of higher
education niall ferguson barry weiss
heather heing joe lonsdale arthur brooks
and i and we have since been joined by
many others including the brave
professors mentioned above kathleen
stock dorian abbott peter bogosian we
count among our numbers university
presidents robert zimmer larry summers
john nunez gordon g leading academic
stephen pinker deirdre mccloskey leon
cass jonathan height glenn lowry joshua
katsvicki sullivan jeffrey stone bill
mcclay and tyler cowan we're joined by
journalists and public intellectuals
like lex friedman andrew sullivan rob
henderson caitlin flanagan david mamet
ayan hershey alisar bamari stacey hawk
jonathan rauch and nadine straussen
our backgrounds and experiences are
diverse our political views differ what
unites us is a common dismay at the
state of modern academia and a
recognition we can no longer wait for
the cavalry and so we must be the
cavalry
so this is really exciting stuff
it's really great so their plan is that
they are going to be
moving through the next few years
beginning to launch degree programs just
a couple of years from now
and honestly
like all support to them it's great
they're hoping by 2022 to launch a
graduate program in entrepreneurship and
leadership by 2023 to launch graduate
programs in politics and applied history
and in education and public service and
then by 2024 just three years from now
to establish a full undergraduate
college
which is fantastic it's fantastic and so
i encourage everybody to go check out
uaustin.org that is the place where this
is located more of these options for our
students more of these options for our
kids
again competition is the lifeblood of
intellectual development and i am very
excited that that university of austin
is launching and congrats to all my
friends who are involved with that
particular effort
how's this for a title ben shapiro show
subscriber destroys like button with
clicks and logic i'd watch that make it
happen gang